tom what is really going on with the
market right now well what's really
going on is from the white house to the
treasury to the lead analyst on wall
street nobody wants to walk across the
line and say it's really happening and
it's really here consensus estimates
from the beginning of the year are
unchanged pat you just read it yet
all the market indicators we can look at
every day from stock prices commodities
everything else is down why are they not
revising it because no one wants to walk
across the line to be the first guy to
say officially we are in a deep bear
market not just a bear correction but a
deep bear market number one and number
two the white house even though we are
officially as of july 1st statistically
in a recession nobody wants to make that
the lead stories and so the white house
and treasury have friends on wall street
and they don't want with midterms and
everything coming up they don't want
people to feed into the recession a bull
market story and so that's why these
analysts are sitting there and sitting
on the news when reality we're in a bear
market we're in a recession but they're
all afraid to be the first credible
voice to come across the line and say
man it's real and it's here because
guess what happens
someone has to do something about it and
that is the white house and raising
interest rates is the tool and nobody
wants that so everyone is scared to fall
across this this is unsurprising to me
but it underlines just how bad the
situation is for the economy so so you
know how uh uh you know how adam do you
have any comments on that on what uh
yeah well look uh i just came back from
new york i definitely
went to wall street i mean it was in the
weekend so you didn't really see
you know the nyse and everything that's
going on during the week during the
hoopla but i walked by the raging bull
right you know the uh the bull the bull
of wall street
and the defiant little girl the fire
girl saw her too
um and it and i
and i remember a quote that i heard
about markets and tom you might want to
weigh in this and it says that um
bull markets will make you money
but bear markets can make you rich
so if we are entering a bear market
or if we're already there okay let's use
that
to our advantage right so when
everything's going up and up and up all
right everyone's making money
but if you position yourself correctly
and you understand what's coming and and
you are prepared then you have the
opportunity to make a lot of money pat
you went off on you're a lot about to
see a lot of people worth a hundred
grand be worth a million you're allowed
to see someone who's worth a million add
another zero 10 million if you're worth
10 minutes like this is the time if you
prepare yourself
uh proper preparation prevents poor
performance right that was what i always
say yep and um
warren buffett was just quoted by elon
musk his strategy the ppp strategy which
is predict
prepare
and persevere there we go and shout out
to valuetainment.com for writing that
article and so here's my question guys
so like somebody like me that
doesn't really know about stocks and but
whatever you guys i mean i'm trying to
soak it in but what do you tell the
average person that's not involved and
you know doesn't know about what you're
talking about getting it they're [ __ ]
struggling right now [ __ ] is bad and
like what do we just tell them hey
listen that's that the white house is
basically just saying hey suck it up
they even said this it's a new liberal
world order suck all this [ __ ] up gas
prices everything we're going somewhere
else like the whole going green [ __ ]
they took out all the white ones binding
got it no drilling no oil no nothing
it's like hey deal with it because
you're trying you're asking what the
regular guy what's a regular guy number
one pat and number two do you think if
trump and i'm going right back to
politics if trump was in because my
cousin was like what would have trump
done different what do you think if
trump was in power i want to ask all you
guys what would it still be happening
right now what's happening right now
first of all first of all did you guys
see
uh griner open letter did you guys hear
grinder open letter yesterday do you
know who i'm talking about i don't know
brittany
can you pull this up brittany griner
writes an open letter to who
joe biden you guys realize she's been
out there months four months okay so
brittany if you're listening to this in
russia and you want to know who to
really write the open letter to write it
to trump he'll probably get you out yup
can you imagine she says i'm terrified i
might be here forever and biden what has
he done what has kamala done i'm sorry
kamala aren't you supposed to be a gamer
here aren't you supposed to get up there
and make a video and say something about
to get her out how was she stuck there
this entire time do you guys remember
when jorge ramos who hates trump
do you remember where jorge ramos was
stuck where was ramos stuck do you guys
remember when ramos had an issue you
guys don't remember this no tyler do you
remember this with ramon you're talking
about university own heart hey ramon
jorge ramos where was he is cuba he was
he was stuck i'll tell you right now
pull it up right now exactly what it was
sick right he got sick and then he had
so he had something going on that he
comes out and then trump trump comes out
of nowhere and defends this guy
so you got a grinder here who is asking
hey that's it
venezuelan government detained him and
him and trump bump heads
who bails them out trump and guess who
he thinks
trump he thanks trump
shout out to him so
grinder if you're listening to this i
can't stand the fact that you're stuck
there i can't stand the fact that you're
stuck there the current administration's
campaign was to protect people like
yourself okay
you were the person they were supposed
to protect and go after to make sure
nobody messes with you you're stuck in
russia biden hasn't made one phone call
to say you better release them or else
i'm going to put more funds and
strengthen ukraine there is zero help
going on here okay zero so here's the
thing which the comment you just made
yesterday guy says to me i post a
comment about the the tweet about i
don't know if you saw the tweet i i
tweeted about gas prices when uh uh
biden's tweet can you go to my twitter
account i'll just read you what i said
when he says uh
yeah when he says so one guy commented i
won't tell you what this guy commented
keep going up keep going up keep going
up uh up up up it's the one when i
respond to biden's tweet uh keep going
keep going keep going keep going right
there okay click on that one right there
uh you can't do it can you okay all
right anyway so i respond to his tweet
biden says something about in a very uh
uh demanding voice which by the way i
don't understand why you read write it
like that
in a demanding voice he says
did you pull it up or it's not letting
you okay i'll just read it to you here
buddy it's okay we don't have to stress
out about it my message to the company
is running gas stations you ready and
setting prices at the pump is simple
this is a time of war and global peril
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you're
paying for the product and do it now
okay and this is my response mother
bezos responded first and he gave an
epic message this is the guy he
supported correct and now he's having
virus remorse okay the white house needs
to knock this off so i say i tweet this
out and i say first you blame trump
then covet then putin then oil companies
now gas station owners what's next
blaming car owners for driving too much
then a guy responds back on instagram
and he says the following it's very
important for you to see how the market
is responding to this kind of stuff and
i want to read this guy's comment and
i'll post my question that i gave to him
he says patrick
we know it's the oil companies raking in
record profit
profits and the government collects
their share through taxes and political
contribution they're all in on it what
say you patrick bit david i don't know
if you speak like that but what say you
patrick david sometimes i talk like that
david here's what i said
why were they not taking record profits
under trump but they are on their bite
why not
forget politics for a second and
actually answer that question and i got
a few more for you afterwards
if they're taking record profits now
and trump is pro oil shouldn't they have
taken record profits under trump so
where does that argument go now
so you said wait a minute do you
understand what i'm saying here so hey
if these oil people are getting rich why
do they get rich under a biden
administration not under a trump
administration worldstar post something
the other day about uh
about and by the way world start
if you were to guess which side
politically world star's audience falls
as a left middle or right
libertarian
go to the instagram post they put when
biden says
uh i'm tyler we can hear you type i'm
proud to say that america is officially
the first country in the world
to prove vaccines for six-month-old
babies here's what i want you to do
go read the response of people on that
post
you know what you realize
more people agree and are on the same
page than you think
set aside identity politics left right
middle center whatever [ __ ] 95 of us
all agree
on half the [ __ ] that's not working out
that's the problem today people are
sitting there and saying the hell is
this guy saying i voted for this guy but
what are you talking what are you
putting out there man this is
embarrassing take this thing off don't
don't put that up there but you think
they're staying quiet because they're so
loyal and they're not going to [ __ ]
admit that they're messing up are you
sure no no you don't need everybody to
be allowed you only need 10 of them to
not be happy and 10 of them are not
staying quiet they're sick of it they're
done with it they're like this is purely
games i'm freaking sick of it when you
mess with someone's kids and their
pockets they get upset and that's what's
happening today so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]